[MUSIC PLAYING]
- When we ask ourselves now,
why we need the humanities?
Part of the answer
to that question
is because we need
to think about how
to survive into a future
that is unprecedented,
in terms of the
climate conditions that
limit our thriving.
And my belief is that
climate change challenges
what it means to be human
more than any other ecological
problem we've ever experienced
in the lifetime of the species.
So I'm curious to
find out for myself,
but also for others,
for my students,
and just for the
broader public, where
can we see some practicable
solutions about how
to be the best kinds
of climate citizens--
which is an international
planetary kind of citizenship,
how to act ethically
and with empathy
in conditions that might involve
certain kinds of scarcity
that we haven't seen before--
--and also how to remain
democratic, as a culture,
here in the United States, when
we're being pressed very hard
around questions of
resource scarcity,
new forms of globalization
that have changed our economy
profoundly--
and also, I think
inequities, in terms
of who is affected
by climate burdens,
that help exacerbate
problems such as racism.
I think it's really
great that the Radcliffe
Institute and that
Harvard University
is supporting cultural
work that addresses
this kind of planetary problem.
And I hope-- because
I'm a Harvard graduate.
I got my PhD here--
that Harvard continues
as it has been
to be a leader in
really addressing
the problem of being human in
the age of climate change--
--and letting this be
at the center of work
in the social sciences
and the humanities
so that the
scientists don't have
to bear the entire burden
of communication on an issue
that it seems is getting more
and more difficult to speak
about in public.
[MUSIC PLAYING]